hallo das sind partner und kafka kafka
ist ein hund der hund ist braun kafka
wedelt mit dem schwanz
das sind sam und oliver oliver ist ein
hund die hunde begrüßen sich kavka hört
auch auf deutsch
kafka macht sitz
kafka macht platz drehen mit hunden ist
schwierig kafka hat keine lust filme zu
drehen
kafka sagt hallo
sony möchte auch einen hund haben
oliver ist weiß und hat schwarze flecken
oliver hat vier beine zwei ohren augen
eine nase und eine route
oliver hat braune augen
oliver welt oliver ist aufgeregt
oliver möchte zu hacker gehen
ali war welt kafka und oliver rennen
über die wiese kafka und oliver spielen
kavka ist größer als oliver die hunde
liegen auf der wiese oliver spielt mit
einem stöckchen angina streichelt oliver
olli war liegt in der sonne
[Musik]
red